hi i'm mike coleman a developer advocate
here at google cloud
in this video i want to walk you through
how you can use google cloud's migrate
for anthos to move some of your existing
windows workloads from virtual machines
to containers
in just a few steps this video builds on
an earlier one
introducing migrate for anthos if you
haven't checked that video out yet
definitely go do so
as this one assumes you perform the
prerequisites we outlined there
at the end of the last video we had set
up our service accounts enabled the
necessary apis and created a processing
cluster
before we can do the actual migration we
need to complete a couple of windows
specific prerequisites
we need to add a windows node pool to
our processing cluster
and ensure we have a windows build vm we
need the node pool to ensure that we can
analyze windows applications and unlike
with linux applications
there isn't an automated container build
step with windows apps
migrate for anthos will create a docker
file but you'll need a vm on which you
can do the actual docker build
as well as push the resulting image up
to the google container registry
so let's set both of those up i've
logged into the google cloud console and
i'm ready to get started so i'll click
on processing cluster
i'll go ahead and add the node pool
we're going to go with one node
so let's click that there come over here
we're going to change this to the
windows semi-annual channel release
so we'll click make changes i want to
come down here and i want to use an
n1 standard 4 as my machine for the node
pool
and we'll come down and then for
security i want to make sure that i have
full platform access and we'll click
that
and then we'll click create and that
will add the node pool so next thing i
want to do is i want to add
the machine that i'll use to build my
docker images so we're going to come up
over here
and we're going to click on compute
engine virtual machine instances
we'll do create instance
we'll call the machine win build one
we're going to put it in the us
west 2a region we're going to use an n1
standard 4
and we'll use windows server 1909 data
center edition
we want to come down here and ensure we
have full platform scope again
and we'll click create and that will go
off and create our build machine
with those additional prerequisites set
up let's jump into using
migrateforanthos to migrate a windows
application
as a brief recap migrate for anthos has
three primary components
the first is the discovery tool which
assesses how successful a migration of a
given application might be
next is the processing cluster a
kubernetes cluster that is used to
examine the source vm
and create the migration plan as well as
execute the actual migration
and finally mgctl a command line tool
like kubectl for interacting with the
processing cluster
we'll do most of our work in the console
today but i will show you a bit of mig
ctl
and again to quickly recap a migration
generally consists of the following
steps
creating a google cloud project setting
up service accounts and enabling the
appropriate apis
creating a migration processing cluster
and a build vm in the case of windows
choosing and qualifying your workload
defining your migration source creating
a migration plan
and adjusting the migration plan to
ensure it meets your needs
creating the deployment artifacts and
deploying the newly containerized
application
we now have covered the first two items
so let's jump into how you can choose
the right application
the first thing to consider is which
operating systems iis
and net versions can be migrated we
migrate
microsoft windows server 2008 r2 or
higher
microsoft iii 7 or higher web
applications
and asp.net and net framework versions
3.5 or higher
it's important to note that after
migration the resulting container will
run windows server version 1909
in addition to specific versions of the
operating system or app stack
the following application
characteristics make them unsuitable for
migration
applications with dependencies on gpus
or tpus
applications with low level networking
requirements
desktop rdp and vdi applications
and applications with bring your own
licensing in order to help determine if
an application is a good fit
we have the application discovery tool
the tool
outputs a zip file that indicates
whether or not the windows vm is a
potential fit for migration
the name of the file indicates the
results the zip file includes multiple
files with information
on the operating system settings iis
odbc config and the global assembly
cache
i'm not going to go into the zip file
contents in depth and would encourage
you to check out the docs if you need
more information
let's take a look at the migration tool
in action before we do that i want to
give you an overview of the application
we'll be migrating
this is a simple asp.net application
it's got this web front end running on
iis that connects back to a cloud sql
instance
so if i click on courses you can see a
bunch of courses come up those are being
pulled out of the cloud sql database
the virtual machine is right here it's
called symbol university and that's what
we're going to migrate
i've already set up an rdp session into
that box
so we'll move into that now and i've
installed the migrate for anthos
migration tool you can see it right here
collect
info.xc so i'll hit enter and we'll run
that tool it's going to go through it's
going to collect a bunch of system
information this is going to take a
little bit so i'm going to fast forward
the video and i'll rejoin you in a
second
so the tool is finished and if we look
at the file name here
it doesn't say no fit which means we
actually
do have a fit so our application is good
to go and
should be an easy migration we have
completed our prerequisites
and our application is a good fit so at
this point we're ready to go ahead and
create our migration source
before we start creating actual
migration i just wanted to review a
couple of points
first a windows instance can only be
migrated from a compute engine
instance so that's what we've got going
on here we've got symbol university on a
compute engine vm
the second thing is you cannot migrate a
vm until you stop it
so i'm going to come over here to symbol
university i'm going to select it
and i'm going to click stop with the vm
stopped i can now go to migrate to
containers here in the menu
and start the migration process we added
our processing cluster earlier so here
it is it's in the
ui now we're going to add a migration
source so i'm going to click add source
i'm going to select that processing
cluster click next give it a name
windows migration source it's going to
come off compute engine click
next and now we're going to create a
service account so
we can have this done automatically for
us the service account is going to have
the viewer and the storage admin roles
assigned to it so
we'll go ahead and click next and add
source
and that will add our migration source
the source is now ready you can handle
windows and linux workloads so let's
create the actual migration
click create migration come in here give
the migration a name
we'll call windows migration select the
source that we just created from the
drop down
select the operating system as windows
and then type in
the name of the virtual machine that
we're going to migrate which was symbol
university
we'll come down here and we'll click
create migration
that's going to start the creation of
the migration plan and that's going to
take a few seconds
so let me go ahead and fast forward the
video and i'll rejoin you when that's
done
okay the migration plan has been
generated and the next step here would
be to review and edit that migration
plan
so we come in and we take a look at it
we're not actually going to edit it i'm
not going to spend a lot of time here
i'll just point out some highlights you
can see here we're running a net four
five classic application
uh here's the web root directory
information like that port 80.
so all of that looks good so let's go
ahead and save that and generate our
artifacts
now this is going to go out and create
our docker file again this is going to
take a couple seconds so i'm going to go
ahead and pause the video
and i'll rejoin you when it's finished
the artifacts have been generated and
those are actually stored in a google
cloud storage bucket
there's a couple different ways you
could get at them you could go to the
bucket directly
or you can actually use mig ctl to give
you the location and then
copy the file down and that's what we're
going to do so i'm going to open up a
cloud shell
and i'm going to issue that mig ctl get
artifacts command and point it at the
migration we just did
and that's going to give me the command
that i need to run so i'm going to copy
that command gsutel cp
gsutil copy and we're going to run that
in our windows
build machine where we're going to build
our docker image so let's run that copy
command
and that's going to bring down the
artifacts.zip file
so it's been copied let's look at the
directory and make sure it's there
clear the screen and we'll do a dir and
there's our artifacts file
so let's expand that archive to get to
the docker file
so expand archive artifacts.zip hit
enter
the archive will get expanded out and we
will have our docker file
all right let's clear the screen let's
take a look at that artifacts directory
to make sure we got our docker file so
do the directory and there's the docker
file so now let's issue our docker build
command
and tag it so it can be pushed up to
google container registry after the
build is finished
so we'll go ahead and get that build
done there it is it's been tagged and
ready to get pushed up to the container
registry so let's do that next
so we'll clear the screen and we'll
issue the docker push command
and that will push it up to google
container registry this is going to take
a few seconds so i'm going to fast
forward the video
and rejoin you when it's done
as that gets pushed up to container
registry the next thing to do
is to actually deploy it to our
production cluster so i've got two
clusters
a processing cluster and a production
cluster and i'm gonna go into cloud
shell and i'm gonna log into my
production cluster
and then to make sure i am on the right
cluster i'm gonna do a get nodes
and make sure that i see all the nodes
of my production cluster which i do
so now let's take a look at our
deployment yaml and you can see nothing
special here
i'm deploying that container registry
image that i pushed up earlier
and so let's go ahead and do that
kubectl apply minus f
symbol deployment.yaml will create my
kubernetes deployment
so give that a minute to settle down and
then we'll check the status here
clear the screen and let's check and see
if our pods are there
and there's our pod check our
deployments
and the deployment is there now let's go
ahead and expose that deployment
on behind a load balancer this will take
a couple seconds i'm going to pause the
video and i'll rejoin you
when it's up and running all right let's
do a coupe ctl get services
and that will list out the ip address of
our load balancer so we're going to grab
that ip address
we're going to come up here into chrome
and open a new tab
paste in that address click there
paste the address in and that will open
the symbol university website
so let's hit enter there's the website
let's click courses we're still
connected to our database
and if i go back into google cloud
platform and i look at the vm instance
i'll see that it's still
stopped meaning that i am in fact
serving my application now
off of the kubernetes cluster out of
that container
so there you have it in this video you
learned about using migrate for anthos
to move windows workloads into
containers
including how to assess your application
create the migration plan
execute the migration plan and deploy
your newly containerized application
be sure to like and subscribe because
we'll be posting subsequent videos in
this series to cover topics such as
best practices for evaluating your
applications how to migrate linux
workloads and more
and to get started on my great for
anthos today visit cloud.google.com
migrate anthos
you